let's hear from people in the audience
we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord I want to go first to Ben from
Florida things are insane in Florida
they're blocking Holocaust textbooks
they're allegedly investigating a
teacher because she played a Disney
movie for her class that had a gay
character I mean just it's crazy what's
happening there Ben uh what's on your
mind today
yes I can
all right hey man thanks uh so I wasn't
gonna call and talk about that I'm
actually uh uh currently in the Air
Force abandoned for 19 years now and
there's a uh
a trend that's kind of irritating so
you know the right has always talked
about the woke military and so forth
um
my question is
you know what are your thoughts on the
fact that they're saying we're awoke
military but like for example when I go
to the gym
there's like six screens in there in a
cardio room three of which are all on
Fox News and so I've done like a little
uh
I guess social experiment where I've
changed it to like MSNBC or CNN yep you
come back the next day they're all back
on Fox news but now you said three of
the six are on Fox what are the other
three on
Like Home Shopping Network uh ABC and
ESPN
okay
yeah so it's like very biased and so
like I talked to other people in the
military and other veterans and so forth
and there are so many people that are so
far right and it's just mind-boggling to
me as a veteran who's been to Iraq
multiple times yeah I don't understand
how they can continue to support these
ideals like the trumpists and all that
kind of stuff
you ever ask them I mean it sounds like
you have much more contact with you know
I can't say that right now I'm regularly
in touch with any right-wing military
person what what do they say as to why
they're supporting Maga
oh because Biden and the Democrats are
always terrible for the military and
socialists and it's basically the same
regurgitated BS that you hear from like
if you were watching Tucker or right you
know any anything like that so
um I guess I just wanted to kind of get
that out there you know that that the
narrative is the right that the right's
putting out is it's a world military
that is not the case the military
unfortunately is so far supportive of
trump and his ideals and that and all
that kind of stuff it's really kind of
uh
irritating to me and kind of scare him
like dude these are people that I've
gone to war with and they know what we
go through but they do not really
support what our uniform is supposed to
stand for so do you find that your
branch the Air Force is more or less
Maga than the rest of the military
say that it's more matter than you would
really expect
um no offense to other branches I
apologize for the truck going but
um no offense for the other branches but
the Air Force typically is the one that
you have to have the higher uh standards
for as far as asvabs you'd think they'd
be a little bit more uh educated I guess
you could say
um but it's very much to the point where
even if you point out hey look Biden got
us the highest raise that we've had in
the past 20 years right yeah well that's
really something that Trump put into
place I'm like how far off are you guys
yeah that's tough that's tough so are
you this is your career you're in the
middle you're a career military person
correct do you see yourself shifting to
Something in the private sector at some
point or you want to stick it out
so I
I left till I can retire oh okay
yeah I'm gonna ride it out and you know
I might do over 20 but to be honest with
you man if if Trump somehow finds his
way back into uh to DC it may be time to
punch out before it gets even worse so
well but but by then you'll be able to
retire it sounds like because it'll be
more than a year before that happens
right but you know sometimes you know I
at once I thought about man maybe I'll
do over 20 22 25 years I do love my job
yeah at the same time it's getting
harder and harder every year man to
stick it out so yep no I understand that
listen Ben from Florida fascinating
insights thank you for your service and
I appreciate you calling in
all right Dave thanks for talking to me
all right there has been from Florida
wow I mean downright scary stuff
happening in the military and we we know
it right I mean we've covered extremism
in the military white supremacy in the
military Etc sometimes it can be tough
to maintain an emotional connection with
your significant other you might work in
different places at different times
there might be a kid in the way it can
be hard to find time for date nights
especially because kids demand so much
attention which is why I love our
sponsor paired which is the app for
couples the app will prompt you with a
daily question or a game or a guided
conversation all designed by Leading
psychologists and the point is to just
have a deeper connection with your
partner boost intimacy build a deeper
knowledge of one another my girlfriend
and I will use the prompts on paired
throughout the day to stay connected for
instance we answered a prompt about what
we remember most from the early days of
the relationship it really helps us
learn new things and there can be funny
moments as well an independent study
found that couples using paired saw 36
percent increase in the quality of their
relationship and giving a paired
subscription as a gift is also a really
great idea you can try it free for seven
days and get 25 off a subscription go to
pair.com Pacman the link is in the
description